hi there Steve Kaufman I'm gonna stay
with this theme of attitude and
motivation which is so important to
language learning but first a
housekeeping note I had said that I
would do videos in different languages
and I haven't been doing it so here's
what I plan to do I have written up a
blog post at my blog which you can see
you know the link to it in the
description here and I'm gonna basically
cover this material in I don't know
seven eight nine ten languages we'll see
so because I you know I've been
struggling with this idea that am I
gonna write a transcript or a
translation and stuff so it'll all be
there in English I'm gonna essentially
talk about the same thing in each
language if anyone of you is either a
learner of one of these languages or a
native speaker and wants to provide a
transcript we'll put it up but I'm not
gonna transcribe it in different
languages and today I'm gonna speak in
English but immediately thereafter in
French by the way today is Canada Day
July 1st Canada's national holiday so
congratulations to all Canadians
motivation I saw a very interesting
video on te D or Ted by a gentleman
called Scott Yeller who is a professor
of gosh I don't remember
psychology maybe at a university in the
States and he referred to self
motivation and in fact the whole talk is
about self motivation you'll find a link
in my blog post and he says there are
three key questions that one needs to
ask oneself with regard to self
motivation and these have tremendous
application for language learning and
and of course remember that motivation
is the overwhelming factor in success if
we want to become fluent the key to
fluency is motivation number one he says
ask the question can I do it this with
regard to any task but if you want to
approach this task with confidence you
have to answer yes to the question can I
do it well this really applies to
fluency if you don't think you can make
it if you don't think you can read
the end of your journey why start you
have to have this sense I can do it now
I must admit that before I achieved
fluency in a second language which was
French for me back when I was 17 years
old I didn't realize that I could do it
I had no concept of I hadn't done it
before but once I achieve fluency in
French I was confident that I could
achieve fluency in any language and the
next one for me was Chinese and I
remember a friend asking me do you run
at what if you fail
I had no feeling that I could possibly
fail because I had already learned a
second language so first question is can
you do it you have to answer yes and if
you haven't done it before
give yourself the benefit of the doubt
because as I say if you're not confident
that you're gonna reach the peak of the
mountain don't climb the mountain you're
not gonna if you don't think you can
reach your destination
don't start the journey so first
question can I do it
tell yourself yes the second question
was will it work again whatever I am
doing you know is whatever method I'm
using going to work this has real
application for anguish learning if
you're sitting in a classroom and you
don't think the methods are working if
you don't think the teacher is good if
you don't think the textbook is good
whatever method you're using if you
don't believe in it you don't have the
confidence you're not gonna get there
and I did a video about what I call the
placebo effect and just the fact that
you believe in your method is going to
make you more likely to succeed because
you believe in it just as when they do
these medical tests and people on the
placebo do better than people who have
no medicine so you have to believe that
whatever you're doing works now as you
know I believe that a lot of input
enjoyable input interesting input as the
major focus is the best way to learn but
there are people who have other views so
as long as you believe in the method
then
you will be confident that you can
succeed if you don't like the way you're
learning find a different method and the
third question that Scott Gellar asks is
is it worth it and this is very
important if the task if you don't feel
a task is inherently worth it
you're not gonna pursue or persevere in
this task is language learning worth it
well obviously I believe it's worth it
I've done it you know
over a dozen times I can go on a boat
it's good for your brain
Stig's off dementia good for our
cognitive skills I've made lots of
friends I access my literature however
you have to feel that you have to feel
it's worth it
and I mean it to me it's it's it's a
no-brainer
in order to prepare for my little talks
now in different languages I have the
enjoyable task of listening to some of
the audiobooks that I've collected here
in French in Spanish in German in other
languages just to kind of refresh my
brain a little bit so that I might be a
little more fluent in languages that I
rarely use and this is extremely
enjoyable but at the beginning it's not
enjoyable so much you're struggling it's
the text of beginner texts are boring
and and even when you first start into
authentic material it's tough because
there's a lot of unknown words and it
still seems a little bit fuzzy and of
course when you speak you can't find
words and so I inflict this pain on
yourself because ultimately the results
are worth it so you have to believe that
it's worth it so if you can answer yes
to those three questions number one can
I do it number two is it working will it
work and number three is it worth it
answer yes and if you can't answer yes
persuade yourself to answer yes
mind over brain become a confident
learner and you will achieve fluency bye
and thanks for listening